Một bài thống bài tổng thống bây giờ trong đồng rọt người thương thông bảo áp thời cao tới hàng lọt đối tất thương mại
Đánh dấu bước theo tháng trên lực thương mại tần câu
Công hình thử ra đồng từ hàng làm phần trăm để bụng mấy con trăm
Ám dụng với Nhật Bản, Hàn Quốc, Malaysia, Thailand, Indonesia, Campeau Jé, và nhiều nước khác
Mất thời dự kiện khi ở lực từ ngày 1 tháng tám, trở Trung Quốc, nhằm tạo khoảng đẹp cho đảm phán
Đáng chui, điểm mấy cho OH Hệnh vẫn chưa nhận thư cảnh bảo nào
Được xem, lòng ngoại lệnh trong lãng sống áp thời này
Đúng là mả và Brick Phản Ninh Ví Zoot, Brasil và Mexico chỉ trích cây gát trong khi thay lan
Indonesia và Malaysia, Nỗ lực đảm phản và khu trót
Nhất bản và Hàn Quốc, tui bài tổ tiến nguyễn càm kết tiếp tục đảm phản sông phương
Nhà chẳng không để chính xét này nhằm tải cân văn càm cân thương mại và túc đẩy sản xuất trong nước
Ông tròm trò biết đang đà tiến trên với nhiều nước và điện thoại không nguyên độ chung
Dò lãng đạo đúng ngoại chủ động liên hệ
Và kinh tế, thi trường tài chính tròm cầu phản Ninh trái chiều
Cô phía có hạxen nhật giảm mạnh trong khi viên indec tăng hơi một phần trăm
Đúng là Mỹ tăng giá sau với đồng ýên bảo quân vàng và rộn bị đất nhẹ
Các chuyên giá nhận định tối hỗ thư này không chỉ là đón phy ấy
Mà có là nước cầu chiến lợng nhằm linh hình là chất tự thử mạc của tế